und dann eskaliert in diesen tagen der
streit zwischen polen und der
europäischen union dazu muss man wissen
die in polen regierende partei mit ihrem
chef kaczynski ist schon seit jahren
dabei einen autoritären staat aufzubauen
mit gleichgeschalteten medien und
gleichgeschaltete justiz also im grunde
so eine art islamischer staat ja mitten
in europa deep is bestimmt die
zusammensetzung des polnischen
verfassungsgerichtes und dann gibt es
noch eine disziplinarkammer mit der
unliebsame richter oder staatsanwälte in
polen aus dem amt gekegelt werden um sie
durch leute mit entsprechend
rechtskonservativer gesinnung zu
ersetzen das ist so seit jahren sagt die
eu könnt ihr nicht machen warschau in
warschau sagt doch können wir wohl jetzt
hat der ogh den polen eine strafe
aufgebrummt und zwar eine million euro
pro tag eine million euro pro tag soll
polen zahlen wie kann man denn diese
summe einordnen ist das jetzt relativ
viel oder eher wenig
die scheinen ja gut zu bezahlen bei der
tagesschau sage ich mal
übrigens übrigens allerdings muss man
hier die eu-freundliche polnische
bevölkerung ganz klar von der fis regeln
unterscheiden trotzdem sind unabhängige
gerichte und gewaltenteilung für
demokratien natürlich nicht verhandelbar
polen verabschiedet sich aus der
rechtsstaatlichkeit die wollen gerichte
bei denen die urteile quasi bestellen
können so eine art justiz randow ja da
und man zum beispiel keine ahnung anti
abtreibungsgesetze extra scharf und
richter die nicht liefern wollen
erhalten de facto berufsverbot julia ist
regierungskritiker und einer der
prominentesten fälle in polen dem die
immunität entzogen wurde von der pis
nahen disziplinarkammer für richter kein
einzelfall und sehr bitter polens
justizminister gestern zur millionen
strafe der eu gesagt man wolle die tat
nicht einen zloty zahlen müsste gar
nicht die streif ist ja ein euro
im übrigen steht das mit der
rechtsstaatlichkeit ziemlich eindeutig
in artikel 2 des eu-vertrags den die
polen so unterschrieben haben selbst die
gerichtsshows im polnischen fernsehen
machen heutzutage keinen spaß mehr
[Musik]
respekt im namen des volkes hätte ich
jetzt gerne was geurteilt aber die pis
partei hat mir berufsverbot erteilt weil
ich was nettes über europa gesagt habe
macht nix dann gehe ich halt nach
deutschland und arbeitete bei turniers
die sitzung ist geschlossen und nächste
woche wird dieser staatsanwalt gefeuert
weil er einen schwulen mantel trägt
[Applaus]
dass
das klingt vielleicht erstmal ganz
witzig aber polens parlament hat gerade
gestern kein spaß ein gesetz debattiert
das demos für die gleichgeschlechtliche
ehe verbieten würde kaczynski und co
wollen eine andere eu in der es gar
nicht mehr um werte geht also schon noch
um werte aber eben im sinne von bargeld
die haben sogar in brüssel beantragt die
fahne zu ändern statt der sterne lauter
kleine geldautomaten voll süß ja
natürlich steht die partei in ihrer
sehnsucht nach einem europa in dem
einfach nur geld verteilt wird nicht
alleine da ich sage nur ungarn in
budapest hatte viktor orban gerade
wahlkampfauftakt mit dem üblichen eu
gebashe die hohen eu würdenträger sagt
orban wollten die ungarn achtung zu
liberalen prügeln wörtlich sagt er wenn
die zeit kommt ungarn stellt euch für
eure häuser und verteidigt sie riesen
stimmung bei den fans mit ihren brüssel
gleich diktatur schilder der polnische
ministerpräsident phase diese woche
derweil vom dritten weltkrieg mit der eu
was ist da los reden wir drüber mit
christian ehring er leitet das referat
zur gezielten unterdrückung osteuropas
haring
größe gleich diktatur tut das weh ja
selbstverständlich tut das weh aber
gleichzeitig müssen wir uns auch mal
fragen ist da möglicherweise was dran
sind wir vielleicht eine diktatur die
ersten anzeichen übersieht man ja leicht
wenn zum beispiel so ein junger referent
mal nicht über einen witz von uschi von
der leyen lacht und am nächsten tag geht
er an krücken class
alles zufall sein aber es muss uns schon
zu denken geben finde ich die aufrechte
katholische autokraten inzwischen über
unsere eu denken sie wollen eine welt
ohne nationen sie wollen unsere
traditionen auslöschen und unsere länder
mit fremden kulturen überfluten und
reden wir nicht drumherum genau das ist
unser geheimer plan die eu will die
ungarische kultur weg haben die muss weg
ja ich gebe es jetzt einfach mal zu
allein in meinem haus arbeiten mehrere
abteilungen rund um die uhr nur an einem
gulasch verbot
ich weiß jetzt nicht ob man die
ungarische kultur wirklich auf gulasch
reduzieren sollte jährigen natürlich
nicht da gibt es auch noch salami aber
ich mache mir sagen wir als eu müssen
aufhören den mit gewalt unsere ideen
auszudrücken starkbier jahren noch in
westeuropa veranstalten lgbt cure
aktivisten in kindergärten und schulen
aufklärungsunterricht die bürokraten in
brüssel wollen uns in ungarn zwingen
dasselbe
es dürfe nicht sein dass sein sohn eines
tages nach hause komme und von einer
sexuellen propaganda beeinflusst sich
geschlechtlich neu orientieren wollen
euch so außenminister peter sie hatte
kennt jeder gesunde junge geht morgens
zur schule kommt am nachmittag mit
strapsen zurück und fragt nach der
gartenschere
auch hier einfach mal zugeben ja bei uns
in brüssel läuft seit jahren ein
geheimnis für schulungs und
vortragsprogramm so ist es doch
natürlich ist es so ab nächstem jahr
gibt es an jedem europäischen gymnasium
verpflichten den leistungskurs prostata
massage
bitte natürlich ich sage es jetzt
einfach ganz offen ungarn hat recht wir
haben unrecht deswegen verkündigt heute
im namen der eu wir hören auch damit
schluss wir lassen die ungarn frei die
diktatur eu zieht sich zurück und wir
hören auch auf orbans regierung mit
unserer ganzen eu kohle korrupt zu
machen das war nicht in ordnung wir
haben die korrupt gemacht wir haben sie
doch kommt gemacht beispiel orban
schwiegersohn ein kleiner handwerker ist
mit einem einzigen eu auftrag für
straßenlaternen über nacht millionär
geworden das war unsere schuld denn wir
geben denen ja das geld dafür von mir
heute noch mal ein ausdrückliches sorry
wird nicht wieder vorkommen
mit einem symbolischen akt befreie ich
jetzt ungarn offiziell von doch der eu
hier zwölf milliarden euro müssten wir
den eigentlich bald überweisen
skrupellos wie wir sind in der
glücklichen 5 milliarden aus dem eu
haushalt plus 7 milliarden aus dem
corona vor schluss damit ihr müsst nie
wieder unser dreckiges geld nehmen kein
cent mehr der scheck wird symbolisch
verrissen
ein konto hat mein gott die eu kann
wirklich gar nichts christian ehring
meine damen und herren
die leute ich wollte euch nur um ein
kleines auto bieten einfach anklicken
macht's gut
hallo
hast du scheiße fährt haye